third there's a concept of state action
a barrier posed by both by the due
process and privileges and immunities
clause and viewed as anachronistic by
proponents of the 21st century
Constitution is the requirement of state
action as a precondition for the
enforcement of constitutional rights and
in the civil rights cases another post
Civil War precedent the Supreme Court
asserted that the 14th amendment
prohibited only the abridgement of
individual rights by the state they said
it is state action of a particular
character that is prohibited the
wrongful act of an individual is simply
a private wrong and if not sanctioned in
some way by the states we're not done
under state authority the individuals
rights remain in full force however for
advocates of a 21st century
constitutionalism if fairness and equity
as they perceive these are to be
achieved the Constitution must become
more like a general legal code
applicable indistinguishably to matters
public and private Fourteenth Amendment
claims of due process and equal
protection and privileges and immunities
must be applied to private institutions
as they now apply exclusively to state
institutions consider for example an
institution that you may have heard
about effect within the last few minutes
Hillsdale College despite being the
embodiment of a thoroughly private
institution government officials have
sought to justify the imposition of
federal rules and regulations upon
hillsdale by characterizing it as the
equivalent of a state entity on the
grounds that have received public grants
and aid when in response to this
argument and in order to retain its
independence Hills rejected further
grants-in-aid the government then sought
to justify its rules and regulations on
the grounds that Hillsdale was the
indirect beneficiary
grants and aids going to individual
students such as GI benefits once again
in response to this rationale Hillsdale
asserted its independence by disallowing
its students from receiving public
grants even those earned is in the case
of GI benefits and instead bolstered its
own scholarship resources we have thus
witnessed a steadily more aggressive
effort by government regulators to treat
a variety of private institutions as the
equivalent of the state and thereby to
extend the reach of the Fourteenth
Amendment however it'd be so much more
convenient simply to nullify the state
action requirement altogether and that
is what's proposed professor Mark touch
net of Harvard Law School instructs us
times have changed and that he would
overrule the civil rights cases he says
the state requirement doctrine
contributes nothing but in clarity to
constitutional analysis it works as a
boogeyman because it appeals to a vague
libertarian sense that Americans have
about the proper relationship between
themselves and government it seems to
suggest that there is some domain of
freedom onto which the Constitution
doesn't reach we would be well rid of
the doctrine professor tush net succeeds
in this mission hillsdale's policies
concerning such things as tuition
diversity admissions curriculum
multiculturalism affirmative action and
discipline will each have to pass the
scrutiny and receive the imprimatur of
judges